so biggie how your audition's coming why
you want to know jenny you are not
auditioning no i'm not i did not say
that no um i was just making
conversation i'll be right over here
dustin
everybody wants to be a star
yo it's a lot more to it than just
singing though you gotta have the moves
the stamina ain't not the truth
absolutely epic that's actually tisha
campbell and the iconic 90s sitcom
martin opposite comedian and actor
martin lawrence it ran from 1992 to 1997
and was one of fox network's highest
rated shows winning an naacp award in
1994.
now the cast members of martin have
reunited to celebrate the show's 30th
anniversary 30th anniversary as part of
a special premiering on bet plus which
like cbs is part of the paramount global
family in this preview tasha campbell
she talks about trying to make martin
laugh during the high school reunion
episode
i remember telling t that she don't be
afraid to be crazy don't be afraid to go
for lucille ball all of them
they're not afraid go for it and she did
just that all i wanted to do was make
him laugh i wanted to see that thing
that he has in his eyes where he just
goes
like that right
in the table ring when i turned to him
and i said i got hit with the nova team
and he goes
all right i would get a high off of
making him laugh but i was nervous yeah
yeah i was really nervous yeah you were
tasha campbell joins us right now good
morning how are you doing great guys
thank you
so glad to have you this show it was
epic in the sense that it resonated with
pop culture in a different type of way
we're talking music
fashion of course the different
celebrities that were on the episodes
but the catch phrases yes everything
from you go girl
damn gina
all of that
we don't remember that decades so good
so many people still
love this show and then quote these
lines you know what it's so interesting
like i remember being on the set and we
used to talk talk to the hand was from
us as well
and i would go why are people putting
their hands in other people's faces like
you know someone can get their hand
chopped off
doing that it's it's so funny how it
resonated with the audiences but i think
mostly i think people really resonated
with
the fact that we were two young people
in love two young black couples because
all we really had was claire and cliff
and so
to see that to see
two young people trying to figure it out
with their friends and i think that's
what really made you know people really
love the show and really embrace it the
show ran for five seasons it went out
completely on top when you walked back
in for the 30th anniversary of getting
on that set that's 25 years later my
math is right i'm a journalist not a
mathematician but so what was that like
just being back it was incredible it was
like we were going to start work all
over like right then we were ready to
start and everything was going to start
working and it was amazing like just
being with everybody we were finishing
each other's sentences we were joking we
were laughing it was like being on set
again i know it was really fun to see
you guys together too because you could
tell there's love there you know when
the show ended there was tension between
you and mark you had filed a lawsuit
against him and he said it wasn't true
how were you able to get back on track
with him because clearly you guys have
worked it out we're part we are we
worked really hard to
reconnect
to
forgive and it really this reunion is
about
a celebration of everything that we did
everything that we accomplished and our
growth as human beings
and so we concentrated mostly on that on
that but i look at your life though and
your career teacher because you have
been through it
you have you've been through it you had
a high publicized divorce yes you had
your career didn't go the way you wanted
it to and now you're sitting here
resplendent and orange what did you
learn about yourself and how are you
feeling these days because you look like
a gazillion bucks i am the happiest i
have ever been in my life why i'm happy
you know what i it was a little it was a
combination of the newfound freedom um
in my life and
covet isolation i really had to sit with
myself and my children so you got the
rona too yeah right but it was it was
you know that whole time where i got to
rediscover who i was because i've been
paying bills since i was five years old
and where'd you learn about yourself i
learned that i'm super intelligent oh
nice and resilient nice and um that i
was a really good role model for my kids
yes and that i love i loved being a
mother not just your kids not just yeah
well thank you
i took being um married very seriously i
took being a mother very seriously and
at this point it's really about who am i
right and discovering who i am and
everything that you go through it's like
a beautiful devastation you're gonna
learn something
something really interesting yeah about
yourself sometimes things come in a
really complicated interesting ugly
gift yeah it's wrapped in a in a very
strange package and i just learned so
much about myself and i i
i really am the happiest i've ever been
involved and are you sitting there going
i like me i really do like myself and i
discovered that i'm a writer
um i knew i could write but you know you
have people in your ear telling you for
forever that just do your you know stay
with your day job yeah and you go you
know you don't but martin is still on
the air luckily it is okay so if it
comes on and it's playing do you look
you're right nate it's never left there
do you stop and watch it and go i was
good or do you click through you know
what i
i keep a good millennial around me at
all times to keep it popping
but they would always quote some of the
euphemisms or some of the lines from the
show and i i started watching it because
this one woman that i was hanging out
with she watched it every day and she
forced me and so i started watching it
and i was like wow this is a really good
yeah
well listen um you know we all feel like
family members of you yeah
not just on martin but before and after
that and thank you for always being a
representation like excellence on camera
my god yeah truly gifted
sing dance and of course you can act we
appreciate you and as family members we
just want to say we are proud of you yes
i'm so glad you're in a good place
martin there were union premieres
thursday on b-e-t plus